i don't want to be like abracadabra you
know or like
so i thought why not make it
creepy auditions are the bane of most
actors existence the booking ratio is
honestly depressing it's no different
for the a-list actors although at this
point in their career a lot of them are
just getting offered the part but the
hustle was real in those formative years
let's take a peek at some of our
favorite actors audition tapes from
before they got famous
it's about five and a half months the
audition process casting director sarah
finn and her team looked at 7 500 tapes
in search of their spider-man and they
met with roughly 200 different boys
ultimately the role went to tom holland
because he was so different from
everyone else he was energetic real
grounded and full of attitude he's a
great actor but being able to do a
standing backflip definitely helped him
secure the role it's tough man it's
tough i'm not gonna lie it's unlike any
process i've ever been through the
stranger things casting was looking for
actors who had something in common with
their characters and for 11 they were
searching for a girl who was not only
willing to shave her head but embrace it
millie bobby brown faked her american
accent the entire call so they wouldn't
find her natural accent a concern my
name is millie brown i'm 11 years old
finn wolfhard landed the role with a
blurry iphone video that his dad took
and not only that the poor kid was sick
i'm finn wolfhard i'm sick you've gotta
have some major talent for them not to
just pass you right by for that daker
did the unthinkable to land his role on
stranger things
he danced shirtless to hungry like the
wolf apparently zachary levy looks for
actors who are willing to be silly in
their auditions because he needs them to
feel comfortable acting like idiots
reacting to nothing
it's not funny you know why because i'm
stuck here in order for stranger things
to work they knew they needed a strong
cast of kids so the best casting
director in the business was brought in
carmen kuba the duffer brothers only had
a pilot episode written at the time so
all the kids read from a similarly
styled movie stand by me the kids they
auditioned either came from broadway or
already had a few movie credits up their
sleeve gate and maserato did les miz at
12 caleb mclaughlin played young simba
in broadway's the lion king and noah
schnapp the youngest of the bunch had
starred in movies
scarlett johansson auditioned for the
1995 version of jumanji when she was
just 11 years old she lost out on the
part to kirsten dunst in the end could
you imagine how things might have been
different if she got the role maybe
scarlett would have played mj in the
2001 spider-man instead i am so lucky
how many kids in the world would pay to
be doing this right now there were over
40 000 applicants for harry potter which
was whittled down to 300 screen tests
director chris columbus said dan at his
core is essentially a really good person
and i felt that that's what harry was
daniel radcliffe didn't need any felix
felicis liquid luck to land him the role
he was just too darn cute
that's what's under the trapdoor the
sorcerer's stone a lot of a-listers
auditioned for the role of ali in the
notebook jennifer lawrence was too young
reese witherspoon a bit too old jessica
beale had to do her audition covered in
fake blood because she was filming
chainsaw massacre at the time britney
spears was the second choice but the
director was worried about making a
britney film eventually the role went to
rachel mcadams
and they were wonderful but they were
very irresponsible
check out this tape of robert downey jr
auditioning for a movie called backdraft
in 1991 no sir
it's not going to happen sorry
he auditioned three times for the role
brad pitt and keanu reeves also
auditioned ultimately the role went to
billy baldwin because he looked more
like he could be kurt russell's brother
jason mamoa is another example of actors
getting creative to land the role he did
a haka chant for his game of thrones
audition
which are primarily done before war i
was unsure if i was going to do it i
asked my buddy and he's like yeah you
got to do it but it was weird check out
this video of jennifer lawrence
auditioning for a movie called lullaby
in the end the role went to jessica
barton lawrence has been turned down for
a lot of big name roles like twilight
and alice in wonderland we're so glad
she was nobody's second choice for the
hunger games it was finally a perfect
match
i'll destroy their stuff while they're
chasing us
selena gomez was such a cutie with her
little button nose her breakout audition
was for disney channel at the time she
was taking singing lessons and she was
obsessed with disney channel and wanted
to be a singer and an actor i want to do
that when i get older i want to be both
you know
we're so happy that worked out for her
and me my friend like to play around so
like i'm selena
we're watching disney channel matthew
mcconaughey auditioned for dazed and
confused 28 years ago
it'd be a lot cooler if she did
he's still quite proud of that audition
because he had no idea it would shape
his future three-day job for a summer
hobby and 28 years later
i still got a little summer job that
turned into a career this is rose
byrne's audition she did forget him to
the greek which by the way she nailed it
no i know that but i thought to myself i
just turned 25. this movie likely put
her down the comedic path as a lot of
the movies she did following this were
all comedies it isn't hard to get
typecast in hollywood but honestly every
one of her acting choices is pure
comedic gold and we can't get enough of
it it's just a metaphor
it means something that's uncontrollable
has momentum for her star wars audition
daisy ridley had to perform an
incredibly intense scene and tears were
streaming down her face the director
gave her a few small adjustments and her
performance had him saying oh my god get
out of my head originally miley cyrus
was auditioning for the role of lily in
hannah montana the cutest thing about
her audition has to be that she did it
with her dad billy ray cyrus
i just can't go okay
they refused to cast her at first
because she was just too young for the
part but she kept auditioning and
eventually she landed it maybe by the
time they finally cast it she'd grown up
just enough i think it would be easier
this way amelia clark was auditioning
for the movie belle here whenever he
looked at me i somehow felt right in
this world she didn't end up getting the
role and it went to sarah gadden instead
but check out this cool comparison for
their audition takes
she still did a fantastic job demi's
singing voice has always been incredibly
strong this recording is supposedly from
the demo reel she submitted for camp
rock
if you won't let me give all of me
which means she had to have been 15 or
younger when she recorded it
megan fox's audition for transformers
honestly seems like it was a bit
uncomfortable her performance was great
but the only thing director michael bay
asked megan when she was auditioning was
if she could run and if she had a nice
stomach so i figured i'm going to be
running hopefully not naked but i'll be
running in a belly shirt maybe canadian
actor jim carrey is auditioning for snl
here one of the staff said they didn't
think the series creator lorne michaels
would like it so it was never shown to
him and honestly jim carrey's got a
special kind of humor that not everybody
finds funny
very gratifying thing in my life to
to have done a few characters that keep
revisiting new generations of people
it's so inspiring to see some of our
favorite stars audition for roles they
never got only to land that big break
just a few auditions later and see just
where their careers took them like
selena who followed her dream to be a
double threat we're going to have to go
back and re-watch hannah montana now
because we don't remember her being that
young in the show whose audition brought
back nostalgia for you the most let us
know in the comments